[Música]
más
y
[Música]
hace algo más poquitito más de 40 años
comenzó mi travesía
yo supongo que el vaivén en el líquido
amniótico de la panza de mi mamá
debió marcar me de un modo irreversible
ella se enteró de mi existencia
estando en viajes
desde entonces
y viajar la vida
esto de salir al mundo
me permite navegar mi naturaleza
yo creo que sacar pasajes con destino a
algún lugar
te permite finalmente llegar a vos mismo
a tus luces y a tus sombras
viajar es un camino que a cada paso me
requiere desaprender y abrirme a nuevos
aprendizajes
son precisamente esos aprendizajes que
procuro luego trasladar al resto de mi
vida los que me gustaría compartir con
ustedes
conozco casi 40 países entre américa
europa áfrica y asia
andado solas
bueno nunca se está del todo solo
también he viajado con amigos y con
conocidos y con completos desconocidos
he atravesado cielos hasta en parapente
y ríos y mares y montañas
he mirado hacia abajo desde edificios
altísimos algunos de los más altos del
mundo
y hacia arriba desde cavernas
insondables
he dormido en hoteles lujosos
y también en tiendas de campaña en medio
del desierto de la selva
hasta he atrapado cocodrilos en el norte
de entre ríos bueno chiquitos
he estado en lugares de paz
de esa paz que es tanta que vuelve
pequeño bajo un manto de estrellas
y también en lugares que atraviesan
momentos conflictivos
tengo amigos en muchos lugares del mundo
estudié en mi tierra y en otras lejanas
a ver si les paso me han amado en
venecia
pero también me dejaron en san pablo
porque te dejan en otros lugares del
mundo
y todas estas experiencias sin excepción
me han obligado a estar en modo presente
ahí en el instante gestionando momento a
momento
recuerdo una vez en malta se me dio por
manejar un auto la inglesa esto de
volante a la derecha casa de cambio a la
izquierda conduciendo por el carril
izquierdo se imagina en mi cabeza
más bien concéntrate está todo bien
tranquila en esas circunstancias no
tenés otra alternativa más que estar en
modo presente y eso
me ayudó a poner al pasado y al futuro
en su lugar
al pasado ir a buscar los recuerdos que
te sacan una sonrisa
o los recursos esto que ya aprendimos
que nos ayudan a vivir de un mejor modo
lo que estamos pasando en el presente y
al futuro ponerle los sueños los
proyectos no las ansiedades
si igual como en aquella experiencia en
malta no tenemos ni idea de lo que va a
pasar a la vuelta de la esquina
hace un tiempo solía decir
que para viajar eran
tres cosas
una saber algún idioma distinto al
materno
o tras haber ido por lo menos una vez
alguna ciudad grande como para poder
manejarnos en la lógica de las grandes
capitales
y también investigar un poco antes de
partir
sobre ese destino al que íbamos a ir la
verdad
es que ninguna de estas cosas son
fundamentales
entendí
que la diferencia entre pasarla bien o
mal estar satisfecho o insatisfecho
estar en riesgo o incluso salvar la vida
no la hacía ni saber hablar inglés ni
saber cómo tomarlo en subterráneo ni de
comidas típicas
sí no
esto de poder establecer los mejores
vínculos posibles
déjenme contarles
que no ha habido viajes
en los que sentí que estaba haciendo el
viaje de otra persona
por no discutir por no perder el tiempo
incluso hasta por agradar
no decía lo que me gustaba entonces
terminaba saliendo en fotos en las que
no quería salir comiendo cosas que no me
gustaban
saben lo que pasaba
para que se cumplieran los planes de los
demás me olvidaba del derecho que tenía
a que se cumplieran también los niños
y me borraba de mi propio viaje
y la sensación al volver era de vacío
claro esto no tienen que haber sido
viajes fáciles tampoco para los que
viajaban conmigo imaginen que ellos
tenían que tomar todas las decisiones
incluso por mí
o se descargaban conmigo
estos no estaban siendo los mejores
modos de vincularme
entonces provee de otra manera y dije
ahora los viajes iban a hacer a mi modo
y me voy a manifestar y voy a decir lo
que quiero y la manera de armar la carpa
es esa que yo aprendí y los horarios son
estos y vamos a hacer estas excursiones
claro ahora si estaba haciendo el viaje
que quería
estaba borrando a los demás
casi parecía que ellos no estaban
formando parte del viaje
al principio de las sensaciones le hice
lo que quise lógico pero después incluso
al volver me daba cuenta de que había
establecido relaciones sin ninguna
implicancia emocional
y de nuevo
el vacío la insatisfacción
y éstos tampoco estaban siendo los
mejores modos de vincularme
me gustaría contarles una experiencia
recorrí toda sudamérica salimos de
argentina 14 personas
volvimos 8
tranquilos que los otros también
regresaron y están bien
pero separados incluso entre ellos
saben qué pasaba pasábamos de subsumir
nos a los modos de los demás sin escalas
a imponer los nuestros
y esto tiene consecuencias
pero les voy a contar que hay una escala
posible
andando
entendí
que todos tenemos un modo particular de
comprender el mundo de aprenderlo de
aprenderlo con hache de disfrutarlo
conocen esas personas
que le sacan fotos a todo
aunque se quedan horas apreciando un
paisaje o un monumento
a esas personas del mundo les ingresa
por los ojos
pero después están nosotros estos a los
que el mundo les ingresa por los oídos
entonces éstos se quedan al borde de un
arroyo para arrojarse con su sonido aman
a los músicos callejeros sacan ticket
para la ópera
claro el mundo ellos ingresa por los
oídos y hay otros
citan una experiencia entre
eso los van a ver en cada montaña rusa
que encuentren
by lnd
se suman a la ruta de los sabores
son capaces de subir los cinco mil
ciento sesenta y cuatro escalones de la
gran muralla china
[Música]
cuando entendí que todos tenemos un modo
particular
de entender nuestra realidad de entender
el mundo me propuse respetar eso con
fervor
yo les comenté que he tenido
experiencias muy satisfactorias en
viajes
y también otras en las que realmente
sentí que estaba en riesgo mi vida
viene a mi memoria un viaje al cairo
yo estuve en el cairo cuando se producía
lo que el mundo conoció como la
primavera árabe lo recuerdan esto fue
entre el 2010 y el 2013 yo estuve ahí en
el 2011
los que no saben lo que es la primavera
árabe fue un movimiento social que logró
destituir a gobiernos dictatoriales que
estaban instalados en gran parte del
mundo árabe por décadas
eso ahí
conflicto
y además contrariada porque era un lugar
muy distinto a lo que para mí era
habitual culturalmente
tenía que decidir
me tomaba el próximo avión de regreso o
me quedaba
pero si me quedaba era para pasar la
vida
traigo esta foto
pero no evoca el momento de conflicto
porque no pude sacar muchas fotos de ese
momento imaginen cómo lo estaba viviendo
yo
mujer sola occidental periodista cámara
de fotos hermanos formal
pero como ven me quedé
y saben que hice para sostenerme ahí
y si amigos
amigos
y mohamed es uno de ellos
él y el resto de mis amigos
me dieron el pasaporte a la vida
ellos me cuidaron
ellos me enseñaron sus modos de
razonamiento sus maneras de sentir
y aprendiendo sobre ellos y ellos de mí
vinculándonos
sobreviví
hasta disfrute
y esque
andando corrigiendo
entendí que el modo más placentero más
satisfactorio
transitar la vida
es ese en el que los modos de sentir de
pensar de actuar de ser de cada uno son
respetados y las inquietudes de todos
son tenidos en cuenta
los viajes que yo recuerdo maravillosos
son esos en los que para poder estar
bien con los demás primero me trabajé
para estar bien conmigo y después claro
colabore para que los otros estuvieran
bien fundamentalmente valorándolos
porque todos necesitamos
relacionarnos
desde una actitud positiva
y después me exprese claro que me
exprese si tengo derecho a hacerlo y
puse el viaje de mis sueños frente a los
ojos de los demás
y luego le di lugar a los otros para que
pudieran poner el viaje de sus sueños
frente a mis ojos porque ellos también
tienen derecho a hacerlo
y después
del mismo modo en que puede unir sus
aguas
el río amazonas a las del océano
atlántico
y en la diferencia fluir ponernos de
acuerdo en cómo viajar juntos acordar ni
subsumir nos ni imponernos
acordar como marca la etimología de la
palabra
acn es acercar acordar el corazón unir
corazones con un mismo fin
todos estemos haciendo el viaje que
queremos sintiendo que lo hacemos a
nuestro modo aprendiendo del modo de los
demás
los viajes me dan a mí la posibilidad de
navegar mi interior
mi naturaleza
que es al volver
en el contexto de lo cotidiano
cuando procuro poner en práctica lo
aprendido
vivir lo más en presente que pueda
tienen experiencia
de estar en una conversación pero como
ausentes
y estar jugando con un hijo pensando en
cuestiones del trabajo o en el trabajo
pensando en las vacaciones que no
estamos donde estamos ahí en el presente
en el único momento que existe
valorando lo como un precioso regalo
esto es presentes
presente soy yo ahora con mi nervios y
mezcla de la felicidad de inmensa que
siento por estar acá y presente son
ustedes ahí
escuchando generosamente
y presente es el llamado de mi viejo
cada noche y quiero estar ahí
presente
es el abrazo que necesitan nuestros
amigos y darlo
es ese brillo en los ojos de nuestros
hijos de mis sobrinas
advertirlo
en el único momento que existe
también es al volver
en el contexto de lo cotidiano
cuando procuro respetar
distintos modos de comprensión de cada
uno porque detrás de cada uno de
nosotros hay una historia personal
nuestra historia personal
insondable muchas veces hasta por
nosotros mismos
saben que creo
creo que vivimos en un país
que resalta la diferencia
y construye grietas para dividirnos
fronteras para separarnos
palabras para distinguirnos
y concentrados en las diferencias
nos separamos
nos separamos de nuestros amigos de
nuestra familia de nuestros compañeros
de trabajo
o acaso no estás distanciado de alguien
en este preciso momento
y por qué no respetando las diferencias
pensarnos en nuestras similitudes en
nuestros objetivos comunes en nuestros
intereses comunes en nuestros ser
humanos al menos que en eso somos
iguales
en conjunto junto con los otros vínculos
relaciones felices
ni subsumir nos apagando nuestra luz ni
imponernos
apagando la luz de los demás
un encuentro
libre y genuino nuestra mejor versión
permitiéndole a los demás
ser la suya
si hay algo
que deseo profundamente que se lleven de
este encuentro
andando entendí que la clave para
transitar la vida en plenitud
consiste en establecer vínculos
saludables
y sabes
no se trata de tomarte el próximo avión
para dar la vuelta al mundo
sino de abrir la puerta de casa
y salir a nuestro mundo al mundo de lo
cotidiano al mundo de las relaciones de
todos los días buscando ser felices
junto a los
me preguntó
que fronteras vas a estar derribando hoy
y con quiénes
y de qué modo
stark o creando tu mundo